[Musique]
cette semaine enquête laval la ville de
tous les scandales
est-ce que toujours eu une caisse
occulte en aval de toujours une caisse
occulte le contracteur demi nous notre
argent avec sopi l'ingénieur fait son
argent il les lui fait son argent puis
collecteurs de fonds
un système de corruption qui date de la
fondation de la ville c'est l
administration permet en rien qu à
l'époque
et puis avait eu des percussions fait
ses manchettes monsieur le maire il n'y
a pas caché le butin je l'aï dit à
plusieurs glissements nous financions de
façon conditionnelle tenté aussi au
temps qui avait pas une loi qui nous dit
alors comment se financer
[Musique]
bienvenue en quête les rumeurs de
collusion et de corruption polluent le
paysage politique à laval depuis la
création de la ville au milieu des
années 60
mais notre enquête va plus loin et
révèle que système de pots-de-vin
auraient été mises en place pour
corrompre les élus et obtenir des
contrats l'argent de cette caisse
occulte aurait été par la suite déposé
dans des paradis fiscaux ou qu'un maire
n'a encore été accusé à laval mais l'anc
est en cours de l'escouade marteau et de
l'unité permanente anticorruption a
forcé la démission de l'indétrônable
gilles vaillancourt enquête sur une
ville sous haute surveillance
une forte odeur de collusion et de
corruption flotte sur laval depuis plus
de 40 ans dans le royaume de laval
quelque chose qui sent très mauvais
lumet répliqué dans différents scandales
n'ont jamais été accusé ils nient tous
avoir posé des gestes illégaux et ce
sont des insinuations quant à moi
précieux comme maréval paquet d'éléments
disparaître qu'ils veulent ou faut se
venger
djinnit et et je continue à nier
plusieurs journalistes d' enquête temps
de démontrer les pratiques douteuses à
laval depuis des années le système a
commencé sous le régime du maire de
saint-amand s'est peaufiné sous le
régime du maire claude ulysse le faire
et a pris son essor sous le régime du
maire vaillancourt des commissions dans
quel public avortent et plusieurs
enquêtes policières échoue à atteindre
ce qui effectivement d'un certain qu il
ya des matières d'accusation avec les
éléments que moi jubël le secret règne à
laval depuis des décennies sur un
présumé régime de favoritisme un système
où des entrepreneurs des fonctionnaires
et des élus s'enrichirait certains
décident aujourd'hui de dénoncer ce
système
donc c'est un système qui était bâtie
pour pour voler des contribuables
certaine manière on peut dire ça c'est
vraiment volé l'histoire où
effectivement
c'est un cercle très restreint d'hommes
d'affaires et d'élus qui contrôlerait
laval un petit groupe puissant que l'on
surnomme le ring qui se partageraient
l'argent les contrats et le pouvoir de
la troisième ville au québec les veut
toutes sortes de solutions
rien n'avait pas tenu 1965 les quatorze
municipalités de l'est jésus fusionnent
et deviennent laval un immense
territoire a développé où habite à
l'époque moins de deux cent mille
personnes
laval devient une mine d'or
laval est un peu de paradis des
promoteurs et des entrepreneurs en
construction à cause de son
développement c'est une ville qui
reconnut probablement le plus grand
développement des trente dernières
années
en 40 ans la population double mais
cette croissance ouvre grande la porte à
la collusion et à la corruption
notre rédacteur en chef claude masson
avait demandé l'aval est réputée comme
la ville la plus corrompue au québec on
la passe à la loupe le journaliste andré
cédilot enquêté durant plusieurs années
à laval
il est à la presse lorsqu'un virulente
éditorial contre la corruption est
publié
depuis le premier instant de la création
de la seconde ville en importance au
québec des faits et des rumeurs de
magouillage de patronage de lutte
d'influencé intrigues de corruption
municipale existe et persiste il n'y a
pas de fumée sans feu de la fumée il y
en a déjà l'aval en 1973
robert roy candidat à la mairie publié à
l'époque un petit livre intitulé comment
stopper la corruption à laval il
explique que l'équipe du maire sortant
jacques tétrault a tenté de l'acheter
pour qu'il retire sa candidature
on appelle le candidat on lui dit que le
maire actuel devrait rencontrer son
bureau on a essayé de me fait comprendre
que je devais rester dans les lieux et
qu'on paierait toute ma campagne
électorale
si je me tenais tranquille je faisais
juste rassembler entre une campagne
c'est aussi la prochaine mise à terre on
me donnait des contrats plantureux après
élection ce genre de proposition fait
partie du décor politique à laval depuis
longtemps au milieu des années 70 la
police soupçonne l'ex maire lucien
paiement d'avoir accepté un pot de vin
de 75000 dollars pour permettre à une
entreprise ontarienne d'ouvrir un centre
commercial
l'ex policier marc demers enquête à
l'époque il remet ses preuves au
directeur adjoint de la police de laval
juge charbonneau
je lui ai présenté les dossiers et les
éléments que j'avais un email
monsieur charbonneau ce qui me dit est
dit que c'était troubles ça méritait
qu'on pousse plus loin la requête mais
il m'a aussi dit qui est difficile de
mordre la main qui nous nourrit
marc demers se remet donc c'est dossier
à la sûreté du québec
il as qu poursuit lé enquête sur
l'administration des mains il ya eu au
delà 60 perquisitions à 7 l
administration paiement va encore aller
pas et puis avait eu des perquisitions
effectivement
cher monsieur le maire et à d'autres
endroits des collaborateurs sur
l'administration et à des fournisseurs
de services bruno faucher ex conseiller
de l'opposition à laval rend publiques
les mandats de perquisition si un
passionnant qu'une fois ici se sentait
pas tellement grave mais de plusieurs
réussi plusieurs dénonciations et
justifiée d'après eux
je suis pour faire des perquisitions
le maire lui sert vraiment ne sera
jamais accusé d'avoir accepté un pot de
vin
il prétend que les 75000 dollars ont
servi à sa caisse électorale
il n'y a pas de cachettes l'aide d'un
joli dit à plusieurs reprises nous
financions de façon traditionnelle carte
est aussi autant carbone noir qui nous
dira comment se financer mais les doutes
persistent sur un système de corruption
le gouvernement crée alors une
commission d' enquête présidée par m
alain brabant le présumés pots-de-vin à
l'ex-maire paiement est au centre des
travaux de la commission pro de 22 75 $
remis au port au maire paiement mêmes
jantes unis aideraient dit quand on
avait exhibé par ses danseurs cette fois
sophistiquée on avait exhibé le chèque
aux audiences de la public de la
commission on avait exhibé le chef et
avait été remis à demain
l'ex-maire paiement se bat bec et ongles
contre la tenue de cette enquête
en 1981 il fait tomber la commission
brabant sur une question juridique
le fils de l'ex commissaire avait
brabant se souvient du mécontentement de
son père y avait une certaine
frustration et les veines certaine
frustration du fait qu'il ya port pu
terminer son travail
est ce que je voyais des 1 4 des
émissions des passagers mission à 40
puis il était bien au fait du mans de la
construction puis demande municipal
pugilat veulent pas ça entrepôt de
peut-être pas publiquement ces deux
coulées certaines informations finalisé
non c'est trop dangereux
la commission brabant est un échec le
contenu d'une soixantaine de témoignage
à huis clos reste sous scellés depuis
plus de 30 ans je pense qu'effectivement
dans certains cas il y avait des
matières accusations avec les éléments
que moi j'ai le dérapage de la
commission denquête et l'échec des
enquêtes policières laisse depuis planer
de sérieux doutes sur l'intégrité des
élus des doutes fondés selon cet homme
d'affaires qui souhaite garder
l'anonymat par peur de représailles
il dit avoir participé au système de
corruption à laval à l'époque de
l'administration du maire lefebvre au
début des années 80 c'est sûr que ça
prend un élu ou des élus qui sont au
courant du système et ça prend aussi des
fonctionnaires écoutez ça peut pas non
plus faire sans les fonctionnaires c'est
pas la majorité des fonctionnaires c'est
par la majorité des élus qui sépare la
majorité des hommes d'affaires alors
c'est sûr que c'est un cercle fermé
nous on appelait ça le ring ce petit
cercle d'une dizaine d'entrepreneurs et
de firmes de génie se partageraient
depuis des années la majorité des
contrats mais pour obtenir ces contrats
plusieurs auraient donné de l'argent aux
fonctionnaires et aux mères on donnait
juste du content c'est sur pied un
moment donné c'est aussi compliqué dès
fois d'arriver avec du content mais on
n'avait pas le choix il fallait arriver
avec du compte à ses propriétaires
d'entreprises et de firmes de
génie-conseil contrôlerait d'une main de
fer les appels d'offres il soignerait
aussi leurs relations avec les élus on
recevait l'exécutif de la ville chez
nous on les mets salés recevoir les
traités bien c'est sûr qu'on donnait des
cadeaux de noël bon ça pouvait des
caisses de vin
ça pouvait des toiles ça pouvait des
coupons d'achat pour une bijouterie a
lancé bon ça on traitait bien mais c'est
sûr qu'à un moment donné
le maire bon c'était différent on savait
qu'il faisait partie de la caisse
occulte alors disons que qu'on le traite
un peu mieux
à la pause une caisse occulte est un
conte les bermudes ce ya beaucoup
d'argent qui circulait on peut parler
même d'un million le million et demi par
année l'homme se transigeait chez
jean-louis le saut alors il ya un cercle
fermé
pis et 100 personnes parlent de ça
[Musique]
des entrepreneurs à laval confirme qu'il
n'aurait pas que participer à un système
de collusion
l'entrepreneur lino zambito affirme
devant la commission charbonneau qu'il a
remis un pot de vin à marc gendron un
proche du maire vaillancourt monsieur
gendron été clair avec moi dit si tu
veux que tes extra soit autorisée ça
prend un montant de 25 mille dollars qui
va directement au maire gilles dianko
monsieur gendron et l intermédiaire
entre le maire ils les entrepreneurs
est-ce que toujours eu une caisse
occulte à laval oui il ya toujours une
caisse occulte
donc c'est un système qui était bâtie
pour pour voler des contribuables d'une
certaine manière
bah oui on peut dire ça c'est vraiment
volé les citoyens ou effectivement entre
1981 et 1989
l'ex maire claude ulysse le faire et son
collecteur de fonds jean louis le saut
aurait touché des millions de dollars
c'est le saut un électricien qui
collectait l'argent des entrepreneurs
pour le maire puis jean-louis le saut
c'est beaucoup d'argent qui circule est
ce on peut parler même d'un million un
million et demi par année qui se
transigeait chez jean-louis le saut
alors il ya un cercle fermé
pis essor personnes parlent de ça c'est
comme secret le contracteur lui
nous avons enfin notre argent avec sopi
l'ingénieur fait son argent piles et lui
fait son argent puis collecteurs de
fonds
c'est ici dans les ex bureau de
jean-louis le soudan le parc industriel
de laval que l'argent des pots de vin
auraient été comptés et c'est paris
entre le show et l'ex-maire le faire
jean-louis le saut a refusé toutes nos
demandes d'entrevue le saut oui bonjour
christian latreille de radio canada
nous nous sommes rendus à sa résidence
dans les laurentides au nord de montréal
ou sa conjointe madeleine le saut nous a
répondu selon nos sources
madeleine le sous comté ou si l'argent
provenant des pots-de-vin nous on a des
informations selon lesquelles vous et
votre mari avait pris de l'argent aux
lavallois pendant des années vous avez
compté ça avec monsieur lefebvre
ce fameux des fois t'es leur compte même
l'argent qu'on donnait alors on arrivait
peut-être avec 100000 dollars pilote
comptait l'argent est là côté sentait
mal à l'aise
une partie de cet argent aurait été
déposées à l'étranger
selon nos informations en mars 1982 deux
hommes d'affaires aurait quitté montréal
pour les permis en passant par toronto
il transporte deux cent mille dollars
comptant dans des valises de l'argent
des pots de vin qui auraient été amassés
par l'ex-maire le faire et jean-louis le
saut en moins de six mois
à un moment donné jean louis ii somme
avait rencontré puis on l'a josé puis
j'avais demandé qu'avec l'argent
qu'est-ce qui arrive avec sa belgique
août
il ya un contact l'appui on va ouvrir un
compte de banque aux bermudes selon nos
sources deux comptes bancaires auraient
été ouverts aux bermudes
un paradis fiscal un conte pour
jean-louis le saut et un deuxième pour
l'ex-maire lefebvre sont allés mettre
aux bermudes sous 2 contre le saut 1
et le conte le so2 qui est en fait un
prête nom pour claude le fait c'est ça
tu exactement ce au japon
c'est un ex vice président de la banque
de montréal roger boutin qui aurait
facilité l'ouverture des comptes aux
bermudes
nous l'avons rencontré à laval il avoue
connaître claude lefebvre et jean louis
le saut meli avoir ouvert des comptes
pour eux
faciliter l'ouverture des gangs là-bas
roger boutin ni savoir comment
transférer de l'argent dans des paradis
fiscaux
pourtant selon un jugement de la cour
supérieure roger boutin aurait facilité
le transfert en secret pour un autre
client de centaines de milliers de
dollars dans une banque des îles caïman
il a été congédié de la banque de
montréal en 1991 claude ulysse lefebvre
a été maire de laval durant huit ans il
nie avoir lu une caisse occulte et un
compte aux bermudes qui était keitel
caissier aimerait bien sûr le saut sur
le saut et paul ghézi cinsault note
organisateur politique
vous me surprenez beaucoup cet argent-là
été transportés dans des valises à
montréal jusqu aux bermudes
ensuite deux salles été transféré en
suisse monsieur c'est de la bombe
écoutez si vous avez des preuves mais
telle est l'offre je dis je les
comprends qu'à ce moment là je suis
coupable deux groupes
le conte le so2 c'était pour cacher
votre identité
comment savez vous ce sont des
insinuations quant à moi
et bien sûr comme me révolte
monsieur je n'ai fait en entrevue pour
quelles raisons
j'en ai fait mais pour quelle raison la
conversation avec l'ex mr lefebvre s'est
poursuivie à l'extérieur de nos studios
il évoque alors un système de
favoritisme envers les entrepreneurs à
laval donc la veille avec ses amis
j'étais mal à l'aise
c'est ça la vérité j'étais mal à l'aise
mon job c'est pas un job dating
qu'est ce qui fera de ce mal à l'aise il
faut connaître l'hôtel de ville comme un
suspect et le premier bureau en train
par l'exécutif s'est déroulée chez
grasset et c'est là que l'on pensait
pour les grumes en parler et beaucoup
d'entre nous pensions nous avons joint
au téléphone
ronald de bosser l'ex vice président du
comité exécutif de laval
de 1981 à 1984 bossi quitte en mauvais
termes
l'hôtel de ville est-ce que vous avez
déjà collecté de l'argent des
entrepreneurs de laval à laval
mais il affirme que lefebvre et le saut
tenait une caisse occulte
oui c'est vrai on parlait beaucoup
d'argent est ce que voulait dire
beaucoup d'argent d'emilie des centaines
de milliers des millions et vous êtes
des millions $
selon ce qu'on a c'est nous le système a
commencé sous le régime du maire de ces
paiements
ok c'est pas fini sous le régime du
maire claude ulysse le faire et a pris
son essor sous le régime du maire
vaillancourt
avez vous l'impression de
l'administration vaillancourt fonctionne
encore comme ça que c'est comme ceux
qu'on a que 3 des contrats à laval ceci
est une caisse occulte en cas bah c'est
sûr
bah c'est sûr c'est sûr ça peut pas être
autrement je vous dis pourquoi ça
devrait être autrement
ben parce qu'écouter j'ai le frigo qu il
était son exécutif de lucien paiement
pendant huit ans après ça il y a été sur
l'exécutif comme président de l'exécutif
avec lefebvre
alors c'est sûr suivi l'école déjà au
début des années 80 la police de laval
s'intéresse aux entreprises de gilles
vaillancourt et de sa famille nous avons
appris que le magasin de meubles md
vaillancourt a été perquisitionné en
1982 ce qu'on cherchait c'était une
double comptabilité
nous sommes ressortis au-delà avec 5 cai
cinq grosses boîtes de documents
le chien de la cale d'amd vaillancourt
les enquêteurs découvrent que des chefs
d'entreprise propriété de la famille
vaillancourt sont endossé avec de faux
noms et étampes et pour des pots sans
numéro de compte à la caisse d'économie
des policiers et des pompiers de laval
c'est une fois ou d'un système ça
permettait d'avoir de l'argent au noir
d'éviter de payer de l'impôt
nous avons joint un des ex dirigeants de
cette caisse d'économie qui menait sa
propre enquête à la même époque et qui
souhaite garder l'anonymat
il nous écrit dans ce courriel j'avais
relevé sur une période d'une année plus
de trente sept mille dollars de
transactions au noir
c'est un système qui impliquait les gens
de la compagnie dans monsieur
vaillancourt pour moi je leur ai accordé
au port était suspect mais l'enquêté a
été abandonnée selon l'ex policier marc
demers et aucune accusation n'a été
portée au beau milieu d'une enquête pour
fraude sur des vaillancourt ont vu mute
aux missions mme effectivement j'ai
voulu garder la contrôle du dossier et
on meurt
fusent et les allégations de corruption
et de mauvaise gestion poursuivi gilles
vaillancourt depuis des décennies en
1995 le gouvernement du québec nomme
vérificateur à laval il y en avait pour
tout le monde là il y avait des soupçons
au niveau du processus d'octroi des
contrats
il y avait des soupçons au niveau da qui
était qui et ac3 y ait ces contrats là
il y avait des soupçons sur la mécanique
d'approbation des contrats à la vie par
exemple l'ex maire vaillancourt a donné
durant quatre ans le même contrat de
détection de micro à l'hôtel de ville à
une ex organisateur politique
le vérificateur jacques martin conclu
qu'à laval il y apparence de favoritisme
dans l'octroi de certains contrats
donc est ce que ça donnait l'impression
que c'est un appel d'offres truqués
presque parce que pour ça que j'ai
mentionné qu'il veuille a fallu que ce
soit yann un peu plus loin mais moi je
aller loin et ça ça veut dire une
enquête policier n'a qu'à fermer cette
enquête policière n'a jamais eu lieu
mais la sûreté du québec aurait
peut-être fait català lèvres davance
ayew c'est une hypothèse que ce soutien
une hypothèse qui n'a pas été retenue
par le gouvernement en 1995
aujourd'hui l'ex ministre des affaires
municipales qui a reçu le rapport martin
admet que les doutes sur laval n'ont
jamais été dissipées il ya ce nuage là
qui hantent auto qui flotte au-dessus de
ville de laval
mais y'a jamais personne qui a été soit
accusés soient tenus responsables ou qui
a été jugé coupable de ces situations là
un nuage si épais que même la sûreté du
québec n'arrive pas y voir clair au
début des années 2000 une autre enquête
surnommée bitume sur la collusion à
laval est arrêté à la est ce qu faute de
preuves il faudra 21 ans d' allégations
de toutes sortes pour que l'intégrité de
l'ex maire de laval gilles vaillancourt
soit sérieusement remise en question et
me présenter une enveloppe un cas du
magic avait dix mille dollars et
que chaque contribution à mon mac ice
électorale le témoignage de
l'ex-ministre serge ménard dans lequel
il dit avoir refusé 10000 dollars du
maire de laval sonne le début de la fin
de la carrière politique de gilles
vaillancourt
je chantais bien que si j'acceptais ça
aussi ça c'était le début de quelque
chose de pioche éventuellement jeu
c'était le chemin une collection plus
plus galants d'éventuels et que je
perdais mon indépendance
non monsieur ça fait quatre fois je vous
dis que c'est faux tout comme gilles
vaillancourt les autres maires de laval
ni encore aujourd'hui avoir agi
illégalement ont débarqué un autre signé
encore je sais pas faire je vais et je
prouverai que pâques est le challenge
que l'on m'attend là c'est très
difficile de percer ce qui se passe à la
vente aussi parce que c'est un village
gaulois
ça fait tellement longtemps que le
système existe à laval il ya tellement
noms qui ont profité du système qui a
peu de monde sombre a parlé mais les
langues se délient et l'unité permanente
anticorruption et l'escouade marteau
frappe à laval des perquisitions chez le
maire à l'hôtel de ville chez les
entrepreneurs en construction dans les
firmes de génie-conseil et dans des
coffrets bancaire et brand gilles
vaillancourt
on le soupçonne d'avoir détourné dans
des comptes à l'étranger
des millions de dollars
vendredi le 9 novembre 2012
il démissionne moi je suis d'avis que
les gens policiers qui ont une
responsabilité bien précises c'est
d'éviter toute apparence de conflit
d'intérêts ou malhonnêteté et cette
responsabilité là ils doivent l'assumer
clairement on n'est pas équipé pour
effectuer la surveillance et le suivi
surtout de ce qui se passe dans les
municipalités on sait déjà que la
commission charbonneau va s'intéresser à
ce qui se passe à laval puis on espère
que les mesures seront prises pour
mettre fin à ce régime là qui dure
depuis une quarantaine d'années
[Musique]
après la pause les méthodes de
financement du parti de gilles
vaillancourt ce qu'elle veut avec
l'argent compte et pour la transférer il
faudra pas l'échec
[Musique]
pendant que les policiers multiplient
les perquisitions pour remonter la trace
de plusieurs millions de dollars à laval
une de nos équipes a découvert que de
l'argent comptant circulait aux crocs
des lavallois le parti politique du
maire gilles vaillancourt a massé des
centaines de milliers de dollars en dons
chaque année mais comme vous allez le
voir certaines des méthodes du pro
soulève aujourd'hui pied des questions
prêter son nom pour faire un don à l'un
des partis les plus puissants de la
scène municipale au québec
il me dit pas ce que tu peux enfin
parvenir ce montant-là contre
remboursement d'une partie bien établie
dirigé par des gens de confiance
d'abord le légal et donc je mets un
chèque de 500 $ au nom du perron ces
deux documents sont un scénario de la
commission d'une infraction le parti du
maire gilles vaillancourt amasser des
dons par centaines de milliers de
dollars chaque année
mais certains s'interrogent aujourd'hui
sur ses méthodes de financement il lui
donne l'argent pur lui donne un chèque
pour le montant d'argent qui était donné
j'ai joué le rôle de maintenant dans une
cause que je n'aurais pas dû appuyer
lancé il y a plus de 30 ans le parti du
ralliement officiel des lavallois le p r
o est un véritable succès de financement
politique
les dons rentrer avec la régularité
d'une horloge les gens d'affaires
forment une grande partie des donateurs
le parti convainc parfois des gens de
données de manière douteuse
réal béland et lavallois de longue date
en 2009
il accepte d'aider un vieil ami un
entrepreneur qui vit à l'extérieur de
laval sacha que c'est une entreprise qui
est familiale qui est québécoise qui
n'est pas aux multinationales et qu'il
se démène pour vivre survivre jusqu'aux
portes sept amis s'appellent gerald
gagner en mai 2009 il reçoit une lettre
avec deux billets à 250 $ chacun pour un
cocktail de financement pour le pro des
lavallois
même si son entreprise est située à 150
kilomètres de laval l'invitation est
signé par un avocat de compte si on veut
contribuer on est libres clés de la
banque of my dépôt légal
[Applaudissements]
cet événement est courue par plusieurs
fournisseurs qui souhaitent tous
entretenir de bonnes relations avec la
ville de laval en recevant la lettre
monsieur gagné croyait qu'il avait le
droit de contribuer
il envoie un chèque de sa compagnie mais
il avait oublié un détail nous
reviennent de la bad
le chèque est accompagné d'une deuxième
lettre du représentant officiel du pro
maître jean bertrand qui lui rappelle de
faire parvenir un chèque personnel émis
par un électeur lavallois c'est là que
gerald gagné demande l'aide de son ami
réal béland
il me dit que tu le faire parvenir à ton
nom j'entends comme si la terre au nom
du père aux lavallois et je vais te
rembourser en conséquence
réal béland s'est donc exécuté mais peu
de temps après il commence à se
questionner quant à la télévision et
ailleurs on revenait sur les élections
municipales et que on avance l
expression prête-noms je dis tiens j'ai
joué le rôle de prête-noms sans le
savoir
monsieur béland décide de se dénoncer
lui-même
j'ai communiqué personnellement avec le
dge par courriels incriminants
c'était je suis coupable dans cette
affaire
le dge a condamné seulement l'entreprise
de gérald gagner à payer une amende de
638 $ mais qu'en est il du rôle du pro
des lavallois et des lettres envoyées
par son représentant officiel
c'est clairement exposé kelly le but là
les rallyes on ne peut pas blâmer son
auteur de deux pauses et transparent
daniel chénard est avocat spécialisé en
droit municipal
il disait à quelqu'un de l'extérieur de
la ville qui n'était pas qu'ils
n'avaient pas la qualité d'électeur et
l'auront on écrit une deuxième date qui
est également une autre bourde parce que
on dit à la personne trouver des
signataires de qui sont des électeurs de
la ville de laval
donc 2 2 mauvais faux pas de suite par
écrit impossible de savoir si le
directeur général des élections a
enquêté sur les façons de faire du
représentant officiel du pro impossible
non plus de connaître son interprétation
de la loi électorale dans ce dossier on
a refusé nos demandes d'entrevue
c'est clair que la cause ne serait pas
difficile à établir au niveau de
l'infraction
donc ça a été normal pour le dge selon
vous de les voir oui
j'espère qu'il est allé voir jean
bertrand c'était le grand manitou des
finances du pro depuis 1984 il a été aux
côtés de gilles vaillancourt comme agent
officiel pour toutes ces victoires à la
mairie de l'argent nos recherches sur le
pro des lavallois nous ont permis de
découvrir des pratiques encore plus
troublante d' usage de prête-nom au sein
même du parti
il nous donnait l'argent puis on leur
donnait un chèque pour le montant
d'argent qui te donner c'était qui sans
ça c'était monsieur bertrand cet homme
qui a accepté nous parler à condition
qu'on protège son identité est un ancien
militant du pro il dit avoir déjà servi
de prête-noms et avoir recruté lui même
des gens pour faire des chèques à partir
d'argent comptant c'était cinq mille
5000 à chaque fois cinq mille 5000 $ à
chaque fois on dirait que de faire des
chèques au nom du père ou des lavallois
équipe vaillancourt puis de rapporter
l'échec quand on pouvait une autre
personne à qui nous avons parlé implique
également jean bertrand nous avons aussi
tenté de contacter plusieurs anciens
conseillers municipaux du pro ceux qui
nous ont parlé on nier avoir déjà
participé au stratagème
bonjour madame gauthier
bonjour je suis gino à elle seule
monique gauthier ancien vice présidente
du comité exécutif de gilles
vaillancourt dans les années 90 a
reconnu qu'il lui est arrivé que des
personnes proches du parti lui présente
de l'argent pour demandé à son entourage
de faire des chèques
[Musique]
madame gauthier ne savais pas qu'une
caméra capte et cette conversation elle
a refusé de nous accorder une entrevue
étant donné son rôle important au sein
de l'administration vaillancourt à
l'époque nous avons jugé d'intérêt
public d'en diffuser des extraits madame
gauthier explique qu'elle demandait à
des gens de confiance de lui faire des
chèques ce scénario se reproduisait à
plusieurs reprises
tous les ans je pense que oui je pense
que oui au moins trois quatre fois au
moins vous devenez après tu n'en as oui
aujourd'hui on en prend conscience des
dégâts
est ce que quelqu'un qui vous qui vous
l'expliquer c'est ce que les extases
légal non non ce qui vous est anormal
non je mal raconte aujourd'hui c'est pas
de la fac ont fait la cote à ou trois
fois rien compris dans ceux qui ont fait
ça personne de vraiment mal analysé
facteurs stévenin conscience qu'ils
avaient puis on embarque el adha nous
avons demandé une entrevue à mettre jean
bertrand les il a refusé d'en
l'entremise le relationniste
il a nié avoir déjà fourni de l'argent
comptant à des gens de son parti dans le
but d'obtenir des chèques de dons aux
pros nous n'avons cependant pas pu
obtenir ces explications sur sa façon de
solliciter une entreprise de l'extérieur
de laval en l'évitant à se trouver un
donateur lavallois pour signer le chèque
je me suis questionnée à propos de 2006
politique sollicite des non résidents de
sa municipalité
les histoires de donateurs prête-noms se
sont multipliés ces dernières années
pour l'avocat daniel chénard des
révélations comme celle faite devant la
commission charbonneau vont ouvrir les
yeux aux gens les gens vont se rendre
compte que il se voit le même le jeu
démocratique est bafouée ça me dit que
le système est malade qu'on resserre les
règles du jeu en conséquence il ya un
éveil de conscience spectaculaire se
fait présente my own et télé pour la
chaux alors je crois que ya un
changement de culture de valeurs
visiblement ce message commence à se
répandre
aujourd'hui avec l'expérience que j'ai
aujourd'hui qu'on est conscientisé
sous-sol en a pas un qui ferait ça je
peux être que le petit pot que je pose
pourrait contribuer sans me l'usiné pour
tenter d'améliorer quelque chose dans le
système
après la démission de gilles
vaillancourt le mois dernier les
conseillers municipaux de laval ont
annoncé la dissolution du pro des
lavallois
quelques jours plus tard l'unité
permanente anticorruption a mené des
perquisitions dans les bureaux du cros
ainsi qu'à la résidence de son agent
officiel jean bertrand
aujourd'hui les conseillers municipaux
lavallois siègent tous comme
indépendants
[Musique]
la situation de quasi monopole dans
l'industrie du cinéma montréalais et
parfois nuisible pour ces artisans
c'est ce que conclut la sodec à qui la
ministre de la culture avait commandé un
rapport l'an dernier à la suite de la
diffusion de notre reportage sur michel
trudel le grand manitou des studios mèze
[Musique]
une peut le dire au directeur de
production toute la province nordiste
avec move ou travailler ou vous
travaillez pas l'an dernier plusieurs
artisans ont dénoncé l'emprise du plus
gros locataire d'équipement
cinématographique au québec
locations michel trudel l'homme qui
dirige cette entreprise est également à
la tête du plus grand studio de cinéma
de la province studios mel's des
artisans dénoncé le fait que michel
trudel était en position dominante
il pouvait empêcher des techniciens de
travailler dans l'industrie selway leur
matériel de tournage ailleurs que chez
lui dans mon livre à moi on considère qu
il ya un monopole à montréal et selon
moins ça nuit à l'industrie faut être
lié à michel trudel pouvoir faire le fmi
n'attend qu'un technicien ce niveau là
je parle de ceux qui ont des équipements
deux producteurs américains nous avait
même confié sous le couvert de
l'anonymat
hésité à venir à montréal à cause du
monopole de locations michel trudel une
critique alors repoussé par le principal
intéressé
alors que jamais personne qui s'est
sentie monopolisé comme vous prétendez
au contraire les gens reviennent notre
reportage à inquiéter la ministre de la
culture de l'époque christine st pierre
qui a demandé des comptes à la société
de développement des entreprises
culturelles
quand on voit des informations de ce
genre en faut les analyser la sodec lui
a fait rapport
elle conclut que les mécanismes de
contrôle des productions
cinématographiques sont adéquats mais il
y a une situation de quasi monopole qui
a parfois des effets négatifs sur les
artisans et auprès des médias américains
l'organisme suggère donc d'étudier la
possibilité d'accueillir une deuxième
entreprise de services audiovisuels pour
concurrencer les studios mel's
[Musique]
nous vous avons parlé en mars dernier de
diplômes à vendre sur le web nous avons
révélé l'existence de milliers de pseudo
écoles qui offrent des diplômes
universitaires sans être reconnu par
aucune autorité
je marchais mondiale rapporterait
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars par année
or il y à du nouveau d'importantes
poursuites judiciaires ont été intentés
contre certaines de ses compagnies
retour son enquête
il y aurait sur internet si melusina
diplômes dont 90 basée au canada
l offre de l'enseignement et des
diplômes universitaires collégial et
secondaire sans être reconnue
officiellement depuis notre reportage
bellefeuille d'université et bud light
secours ont été condamnés en août
dernier par la cour fédérale américaine
à verser près de 23 millions de dollars
à plus de trente mille américains fraude
et on apprend que le propriétaire de
bellefeuille university salem qurashi
opérait à partir du pakistan malgré sa
condamnation et n'a pas encore versé un
sou aux victimes d'autre part nous
avions découvert au centre ville de
montréal
le management institute of canada il ne
s'agit pas d'une usine à diplôme puisque
ces diplômes sont reconnus en louisiane
mais ils ne le sont pas au canada malgré
de nombreux avertissements du ministère
de l'éducation du québec
le management institute of canada
offrait des cours universitaires à
distance sans autorisation du directeur
alain houde ashtian nous avait alors
répondu que le ministère de l'éducation
tolérer la situation ils ont dit tant
que ledit plan que celles délivrées
ailleurs on vous permet d'exister
envoûta l'air ou tolèrent
depuis la diffusion de notre reportage
le management institute of canada à
modifier son site web
il ne fera plus de programmes
universitaires il ne ferait plus que
recruter des étudiants québécois pour
l'université américaine fondée par alain
houde ashtian la dta interna tional
university
georges mamelonet l'ancien député du
comté de gaspé qui a été défait aux
dernières élections a été blâmé par le
ministère des affaires municipales sa
gestion de la ville de percé du temps où
il était maire était au coeur des fins
des citoyens nous en avions parlé dans
un reportage diffusé l'an dernier
georges mamelonet a été maire de percé
de 2003 à 2008
pendant ce temps il était également
président du club nautique de percer un
club de plongée sous-marine à but non
lucratif cette juxtaposition des rôles
étaient problématiques
selon mario cloutier qui était
conseiller municipal à l'époque pour moi
je trouvais qu'il était en conflit
d'intérêts parce que pouvait pas se
séparer de ses deux fonctions
le club nautique de percer présidée par
georges mamelonet entretenait des
relations d'affaires avec plusieurs
commerces appartenant à georges
mamelonet un restaurant une compagnie de
réparation de bateaux et des chalets à
louer
les citoyens ont dénoncé la situation il
y avait un retour d'ascenseur envers
lui-même le club nautique et un usb
elles dorment chez eux mêmes lyonnais et
pg d'un la menace directement dans ces
commerces au coeur de la controverse
examiné par le ministère des affaires
municipales les taxes foncières du club
nautique pendant des années c'est le
gouvernement qui les a payées en 2007 il
s'aperçoit que c'était une erreur et
demande à la ville de percé de le
rembourser
plutôt que de refiler la facture aux
clubs nautiques à titre de maire
monsieur même le nez à faire rembourser
le montant de 36 mille dollars par la
ville de percé sans en informer son
conseil municipal
le ministère souligne que cette dépense
aurait dû être autorisée au préalable
par le conseil municipal
enfin autre remontrances à l'endroit de
monsieur même le nez les circonstances
d'un des zonages accordés pour permettre
l'installation d'une tour d'antennes
cellulaires en 2007 le terrain qui a été
dézoner pour accueillir l'antenne à
partie à georges mamelonet
et ça il ne l'avait pas déclaré au
conseil municipal au moment des
délibérations sur le sujet
le ministère indique qu'il aurait dû
faire preuve de prudence et déclarer ses
intérêts financiers puisque tu es lieu
celui paie un loyer annuel pour la
location de son terrain troisième
reproches du ministère des affaires
municipales
monsieur même le nez possède certains
immeubles il doit les déclarer en vertu
de la loi mais entre 2003 et 2006 ces
déclarations d'intérêts étaient
incomplètes
enfin monsieur même le nez ne pêche plus
l'oursin pour approvisionner son
restaurant depuis qu'il a été accusé
d'avoir pêché illégalement sont permis
il a plaidé coupable et payer une amende
[Musique]
si vous voulez du contact et consulter
notre site internet à l'adresse suivante
vous pouvez faire vos commentaires et
vos suggestions et revoir le reportage
pour connaître notre démarche
journalistique
je vous invite à consulter mon blogue
mais il prendre note qu'en quête et
rediffusée le samedi à 13h sur la
première chaîne de radio-canada et le
dimanche à 18 heures sur le réseau de
l'information
merci d'avoir été là bonsoir prochaine
[Musique]
où